bonjour alexis poulain c'est une
dernière journée tournée vers la
biodiversité la préservation des zones
naturelles protégées pour emmanuel
macron le président qui rencontre
nicolas hulot son ancien ministre de la
transition écologique nicolas hulot
avait démissionné en dénonçant le manque
d'ambition du gouvernement avec cette
dernière journée emmanuel macron veut
prouver le contraire selon vous
non ils continuent à fait dans sa mise
en scène écologistes sont de la place ce
champion de la terre qui rappelez vous
disais qu'il fallait mais planète great
guen après la démission de nicolas hulot
il ya eu la convention citoyenne pour le
climat dont toutes les propositions
étaient enterrés par le président
d'ailleurs les membres qui ont participé
à cette convention citoyenne ont dénoncé
ce double discours c'est une action
volontaire des brêles macron sur le
climat il est de toute façon du côté des
lobbys d'argent d'intérêt et pas du côté
des citoyens qui essaye de faire avancer
la cause climatique ça ce n'est pas
nouveau il ya eu les nombreux
décrocheurs de portraits qui était une
action non violente pour montrer cette
inaction des modèles macron dans le
domaine du climat il parle beaucoup
c'est ce qu'il fait il se met en scène
énormément il est en campagne permanente
c'est ce qu'il fait à marseille et il en
rajoute une couche évidemment avec
nicolas hulot c'est assez cocasse son
ancien ministre qui avait démissionné
parce que justement il n'en pouvait plus
de ce double discours ils se retrouvent
mais ça reste encore une fois une mise
en scène évidemment qu à huit mois de
l'élection présidentielle rien ne va
avancer dans ses dossiers écolo c'est
simplement de la peinture verte de
façade comme c'est de la peinture
sociale de façade que de venir à
marseille pour promettre des milliards
pour les écoles le chef de l'état qui a
donc multiplié ses déplacements dans la
cité phocéenne une visite parsemé à de
polémique emmanuel macron a soutenu jean
michel blanquer sur les achats d'écrans
plats avec les aides pour la rentrée ces
annonces pour la ville n'ont pas été
bien reçue par le corps enseignant il ya
aussi l'hommage à samuel pâtit pour la
rentrée scolaire tout en ayant une photo
des youtuber d'accueil carlito dans ses
mains quel bilan tirez-vous de ce
déplacement de trois jours du président
de la république mais c'est une réussite
selon vous ou pas non cette à hold up
médiatique alors c'est une réussite dans
le sang sont évidemment on n'a parlé que
de lui pendant trois jours mais on a vu
une communication politique grotesque et
indigne l'hommage à semelle pâtit
mélangé avec un hommage en clin d'oeil à
mc fly carlito les youtuber qui l'avait
invité à l'elysée c'est proprement salir
la mémoire du professeur assassiné par
un terroriste
le reste était à l'envi il a défendu son
ministre jean michel blanquer rhin qui
encore une fois pointé du doigt les plus
précaires les plus pauvres disant qu'ils
utilisent l aide de l'état pour
s'acheter des écrans plats sans aucune
preuve sans aucun fondement et bien les
dit non mais vous savez c'est le bon
sens évidemment que les gens ne font pas
ça sans remettre en cause lui les
cadeaux qu'il a fait aux plus riches
avec la suppression de l'sf le séisme et
les nombreuses aides aux entreprises
pendant cette crise du coc vide
entreprises qui ont distribué ces aides
en profite évidemment en dividendes à
leurs actionnaires et qu'ils n'ont pas
évité de faire des plans sociaux donc on
le voit bien emmanuel macron reste le
président des riches il a un mépris de
classe afficher les marseillais fulmine
ils en ont assez d'être utilisés
systématiquement en campagne électorale
c'est pas comme si emmanuel macron était
nouveau dans le jeu politique il était
ministre françois hollande il était
conseiller à l'elysée quand les
promesses de manuel valls sur le plan
ghetto avait été fait là encore à un an
des élections présidentielles
étonnant et le voilà qui revient parader
dans cette ville qu'il a privatisé
encore une fois à chaque fois qu'il se
déplace vous savez le protocole de
sécurité tels que les habitants ne
peuvent plus l'approcher pour venir et
bien comme un consultants de mckinsey
finalement venir faire la leçon aux élus
locaux aux marseillais en disant qu'une
fois n'importe quoi que ça n'avance pas
assez vite qu'il faut qu'ils
s'organisent c'est proprement
insupportable pour les élus locaux pour
les députés bien sûr qui représente ce
territoire je ne comprends pas pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent à part se
poser en sauveur ce qui n'est pas le cas
puisque les marseillais ne sont pas
dupes et savent bien qu'ils sont
utilisés encore une fois dans une
campagne électorale justement emmanuel
macron va-t-il sauver les marseillais
avec son plan d'investissement ont dit
1,5 milliard d' euros d' aide pour les
transports la sécurité le mal logement
la rénovation d'écoles alors ce n'est
pas son plan c'est de l'argent public
c'est notre argent ensuite ce sera bien
sûr aux acteurs locaux de le mettre en
oeuvre heureusement qu'on s'intéresse à
marseille avant lui
je vous rappelle que des parents qui
étaient membres de la france insoumise
avait rénové eux mêmes des écoles ils
n'ont pas attendu emmanuel macron
d'autres l'avaient fait également il ya
un ras-le-bol vraiment terrible et
qu'est ce qu'on voit dans les promesses
faites par emmanuel macron dire c'est
que encore une fois les plus précaires
vont servir de laboratoire à des mesures
néolibérales en l'occurrence mettre en
concurrence les établissements scolaires
avec cette idée de pouvoir choisir qui
vont être les professeurs qui vont venir
dans les établissements c'est simplement
un premier pas vers une privatisation de
l'éducation nationale la feuille de
route le projet d' emmanuel macron c'est
la financiarisation de chaque secteur de
la vie des français de la santé à la
vieillesse en passant par l'éducation il
continue de un rythme effréné d'ailleurs
il veut remettre sur la table la réforme
des retraites la réforme des allocations
chômage elle puisque la rentrée sociale
était en parallèle à paris à matignon
hélas à marseille il essaie de se faire
passer pour le sauveur alors qu'il sort
un carnet de chèques qui lui appartient
pas c'est le chéquier de la république
c'est nos chèques à nous et il fait
croire que c'est lui qui est généreux
non je crois que la pirouette la
communication est beaucoup trop grosse
la ficelle est trop grosse donc les
marseillais en sont conscients beaucoup
de français en sont conscients on a vu
d'ailleurs qu'à chacun de ses
déplacements dans cette ville il a été
hué tout comme jean michel blanquer et
olivier v rang devant le chu de la
timone ils ne sont pas les bienvenus
dans les rues de cette ville donc cette
communication ne sert que reste de la
france finalement pour faire croire qu
emmanuel macron est un président social
chose qu'il n'a jamais été et qu'il ne
sera pas merci beaucoup alexis poulain
éditorialiste pour à votre analyse sur
ce déplacement donc de trois jours d'
emmanuel macron à marseille merci à vous